then i had the idea for the promo i was
like i told mark i'm like throw the ball
at me and hit it so i hit one and i go
i'm gonna i'm gonna strike out and i'm
gonna break the bat like the pros do
everyone's like you can't break the band
like i guarantee you'll break this back
but i was like oh my god [ __ ] thing
i [ __ ] swung i missed my oh and then
[ __ ] snap the bat pretty easy
pretty easy i really didn't think you
were outside there's no way
the adrenaline was running yeah
i see pro baseball players do it but
they're big it's pretty yeah is it for
you i don't think i couldn't do it
that's that's a lot of [ __ ] what did
you just get yeah and then rip the promo
i'm like don't strike out like i did
these jerseys are home runs
that's a
great do you have it on on here uh
mike has it i don't think we have you
have it yeah send that to me i gotta see
that that's so funny send it to the
channel so everybody can see cause
whenever baseball players would break
bats
yeah you know what's funny in jail time
i was because i sent the video jam like
look how easy i broke this back and he
was don't you remember where kids dad
used to always hate on players that
broke the bat like when bo jackson did
it and like those bats are so fragile
they're so easy me and j like no they're
not but my dad since we were kids like
that ain't [ __ ] that's easy so you'll
see like my adrenaline's going because i
didn't think because i didn't want to
not get it done because did you play
baseball yeah yeah yeah in high school
yeah here it is
[Music]
damn it
don't strike out like me because these
are home run baby go to thickboy.com
it's nick friday
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's like an old school baseball card
wait brian you said you played baseball
as a kid like everybody every kid every
kid did yeah i played every kid for you
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah i played i stopped in high school
but yeah but even then i was always but
baseball i mean it's insane like i'm
like like being out there i'm like i
gotta catch this
[ __ ] little ball he kept going
well when you're i went ah one time when
you're a kid it was very common you did
it a couple times yeah
until i was 18 until i was 18 i always
was going out throwing a [ __ ] car on
facebook yeah what were you saying like
it's a
you said if you get three game of losses
three out of ten your hall of fame yeah
if you if you hit 30 out of 10 balls no
three if you have a 300 batting game
if you complete three out of ten passes
you're a half in the nfl you don't have
a career if you if you hit three out of
ten shots in the [ __ ] nba you don't
have a career yeah baseball in your
[ __ ] hall of fame it's a night get
insane
what was my boy mark maguire doing he
was he was beating his hitting crushing
steroids and crushing balls down